.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Ruhige Musik *
* Rockmusik *
(Radio) 27. September 2001,
das sind die Central-News.
# Radio Central - Radio mit Herz.
US-Verteidigungsminister Donald
Rumsfeld sagte vor dem Kongress,
der Feldzug gegen den Terrorismus
nach 9/11 dauere mehrere Jahre.
In die Schweiz:
Die Aktien der Swissair
erlebten auch heute Morgen
einen weiteren Kurssturz.
Sie verloren rund 14 %
und sackten auf 42 Fr. ab.
Die neuerlichen Einbussen sind laut
Händlern auf immer neue Gerüchte
über die desolate Lage des Konzerns
zurückzuführen.
Zur Region: Das Budget der Stadt Zug
sieht einen Überschuss
von 63 Mio. Fr. vor.
(Mann) Das, was passierte,
war unermesslich.
(Mann)
Ich kriegte eine riesige Angst.
(Frau) Für mich war klar,
dass ich sterben werde.
Zum Schluss: Das Wetter in der
Zentralschweiz ist meistens sonnig,
in Zug und im Reusstal
gibt es vormittags etwas Nebel.
Gegen Mittag
ist es dann überall schön.
Hoi miteinander.
- (Alle) Hallo.
Es geht mit Musik weiter.
Ich wünsche einen schönen Tag.
Er kommt sicher mit 9/11
und was es mit uns zu tun hat.
Am liebsten hätte er einen Zuger
Bauern, der auf den Twin Towers war.
Oder einen Firefighter
mit Schweizer Wurzeln.- Das wär's!
Oder ...
- Guten Morgen miteinander.
(Alle) Guten Morgen.
9/11 ist immer noch das Topthema.
Haben wir da
noch irgendeinen Zugang?
Z.B. eine Innerschweizer Familie ...
... die in New York alles miterlebt
hat, jetzt aber nach Hause kam?
Ich arbeitete bei Radio Central
auf der Redaktion.
Wir waren ein kleines Team.
Wir waren ziemlich ambitioniert.
Wir wollten aus einem recht grossen
Sendegebiet alles ausschöpfen -
drei Infosendungen machen,
jeden Tag.
9/11 war natürlich das grosse Thema.
Für uns war das dazumal
als Lokalradio ...
... noch schwierig,
nachdem mal alle News erzählt waren.
Wir hatten den Anspruch,
das Thema noch weiterzutragen,
ohne dass es banal,
trivial oder lächerlich
oder zu regional wird.
Oder jemanden aus der Region,
der in der Nähe der Türme war?
Nichts.
- Ich weiss von nichts.- Okay.
Die Welt
dreht sich wieder mal an uns vorbei.
Was läuft vor der Haustür?
- Kantonsratssitzung.
U.a. der Beitritt zur Pädagogischen
Hochschule Zentralschweiz.
Lang lebe der Pflichtstoff.
Wer übernimmt das?
Ich kann heute absolut nicht.
Kommt, in einer halben Stunde
geht es los.- Sorry.
Tanja?- Georg und ich
machen eine Playlist für morgen.
Genau.
Lucia?
- Gerne, Chef.
Also ...
Ein, zwei Direktschaltungen
am Vormittag
und dann Stimmen aus dem Rat
fürs "Mittagsinfo".- Gut. Tschüss.
(Alle) Tschau.
Und Reto, was genau
läuft bei den Abstimmungen?
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Josef Lang) Die Zuger Politszene
war sehr lebendig.
Es gab starke Auseinandersetzungen,
natürlich auch
aufgrund des Steuerparadieses
und Rohstoffhandelsplatzes.
Das politische Klima
war relativ hart,
aber gleichzeitig
war der menschliche Kontakt stark.
Wir Kantonsräte und Kantonsrätinnen
gingen immer miteinander
zum Mittagessen.
Dort war es eigentlich ein Tabu,
dass man parteimässig zusammensitzt.
Ich sass meistens
mit denen zusammen,
die sich am besten
mit Schwingen auskannten.
Und das
waren eher die Konservativen.
... Konstellation für den
wirtschaftsstarken Kanton Zug ...
Man kannte nicht nur die Kantonsräte
und Kantonsrätinnen,
sondern meistens auch die Familien,
die Angehörigen dieser Kantonsräte.
Es gab ein sehr enges Verhältnis
zu den Parlamentariern.
* Französisches Chanson
aus dem Autoradio:
"Paris c'est toi"
von Michael von der Heide *
Ich habe das Geld
gestern überwiesen.
Können Sie das überprüfen?
Nein, mit e-i, nicht a-i.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Haben Sie es gefunden? Gut.
Die Asche in den Atlantik.
Das ist wichtig.
Ich muss mich
darauf verlassen können!
Okay. Danke.
Ja, das wünsche ich Ihnen auch.
(Langenegger) Ich war Standesweibel
des Kantons Zug.
"Mädchen für alles"
nannte ich mich jeweils.
Ich musste für den Kantonsrat
Mittagessen und Znüni bestellen
und auch darauf achten, dass
die Leute - v.a. die Journalisten -
die Manuskripte kriegten.
Es war sehr eng.
Ist hier noch frei?
Wenn sich jemand dazusetzte,
kam man kaum mehr durch.
Die Räumlichkeit war sehr eng.
(Theiler) Ich war etwas knapp dran.
Ich musste mich beeilen.
Ich hatte zwar noch einen Platz
bei den Journalistenarbeitsplätzen,
aber ich hatte keine Steckdose mehr.
Keine Steckdose ...
Ich wusste,
dass ich etwas improvisieren musste.
Ich musste anders arbeiten
als sonst.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
* Kinderstimmen von draussen *
(Langenegger)
An diesem 27. September
wäre eigentlich
der Kantonsratsausflug gewesen.
Es war ein wunderbarer Tag.
Die Sonne schien.
Wir schoben die Kaffeepause ...
... etwas nach hinten.
Die war erst um 10.45 Uhr.
Wir hätten so um 13 Uhr, 13.30 Uhr
in der Villa Villette in Cham
zu Mittag gegessen.
Und am Nachmittag hätten wir uns
das Kloster Frauenthal angesehen.
Dort wären wir von der Äbtissin
herzlich begrüsst worden.
Es wäre ein wirklich schöner Tag
geworden - wäre ...
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Meine Güte spannt der.
Verdammt noch mal!
Arschloch!
Scheisskerle!
Ich mache euch fertig.
Ich kann mich noch gut
an die Sitzung erinnern.
Am Morgen
gab es zwei starke Traktanden:
eine
raumgreifende Schulentwicklung ...
... und die Vergabe von Aufträgen.
Der Anfang war eigentlich wie immer.
Ich sass
in der zweithintersten Reihe.
Hinter mir war noch eine Reihe
mit CVP-Kantonsräten.
Man hänselte sich jeweils
ein bisschen.
Man sagte sich: "Dieses Mal
stimmst du für mich." Oder so.
Man war eigentlich locker drauf.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
* Beschwingte Pop-Rock-Musik
aus dem Autoradio *
Im oberen Stock
hatte es leere Büros für die Medien.
Die Medien konnten dort arbeiten.
Dort hatte ich Anschlüsse,
um die Geräte zu laden.
Ich schnitt dort oben die Töne
und telefonierte.
Hallo.
- Hey.
* Ruhige Musik *
Stress?
Zu viele Leute
und zu wenig Steckdosen im Saal.
Pädagogische Hochschule.
Schulreform.
Das will sich niemand
entgehen lassen.- Nein.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Ja, hallo?
- Hier ist Lucia.
Ich bin so weit.
- Okay, gut.
Eine kurze Schaltung -
eine Frage, eine Antwort.
Okay?
- Ja, ist gut.
Jetzt aus dem Zuger Kantonsrat,
Lucia Theiler.
Lucia,
was steht auf der Traktandenliste?
Im Moment diskutiert der Kantonsrat
eine Motion,
die mehr Mitspracherecht vom Parla-
ment bei der Schulreform fordert.
Und der Kanton Zug
will der Pädagogischen Hochschule
Zentralschweiz beitreten.
Die Debatte läuft,
vieles ist umstritten.
Wir bleiben dran. Zurück ins Studio.
- Lucia Theiler aus dem Kantonsrat.
Alles gut? Prima, danke.
Sorry.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Ich erinnere mich an die letzten
zwei Leute, die gesprochen haben,
bevor die Katastrophe passierte:
Das war Kantonsrat Martin Döbeli ...
... und Regierungsrat
Jean-Paul Flachsmann.
Und beide lebten
ein paar Minuten später nicht mehr.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Achtung! Das ist ein Polizeieinsatz!
Okay.
- Gut.
(Mann) Am 27. September 2001,
einen Tag vor der Vereidigung
unserer jungen Absolventen,
waren wir
mitten in den Vorbereitungen.
Während der Ausbildungen
sind alle unsere Einsatzmittel
selbstverständlich entweder entladen
oder gar nicht auf Mann.
D.h.,
wir trugen nur eine Schutzweste.
Unsere Waffen waren aber entladen.
Wir hatten auch nicht
den richtigen Pfefferspray dabei.
Auszubildende daher!
So, morgen ist der grosse Tag.
Feierliche Inpflichtnahme.
Haben Sie das Layout gemacht,
Honegger?- Richtig.
Sehr gut.
Wir werden euren Familien
etwas bieten, oder?
Die Vereidigung
unserer jungen Absolventen
war im Kanton Zug
immer ein sehr schöner Anlass.
Die Angehörigen waren eingeladen.
Sie konnten zeigen, wie man eine
Festnahme aus einem Fahrzeug macht,
eine Anhaltung,
eine Personenkontrolle usw.
Wir zeigen eine Festnahme
aus dem Fahrzeug. Einverstanden?
(Hodel) Am 27. September
trainierten wir das.
Ich höre nichts.
- (Alle) Jawohl!
Sehr gut. Wer ist der Räuber?
Honegger.
Danke.
Patrouille. Fahrer, Beifahrer.
Okay, go.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
(Frau) Was ich noch gut weiss, ist,
dass ich noch telefonieren musste.
Da hatte nicht jeder
ein Handy dabei.
Ich musste also
aus dem Kantonsrat raus.
Ich ging in den unteren Stock
ins Kommissionszimmer ...
... und musste
telefonische Abklärungen
für einen Vorstoss oder eine Rede
machen.
Wie viele Ja-Stimmen?
24.
(Langenegger)
Wir hatten keine Besucher.
Das war im Nachhinein
das grosse Glück.
Irgendwann -
so um 10.20 Uhr oder 10.25 Uhr -
musste ich etwas kopieren.
Und als ich aus dem Lift kam,
knallte es das erste Mal.
* Knall *
Was war das?
Man wusste nicht richtig,
was es ist.
Ich meinte damals, weil es keine
sehr interessante Sitzung war -
es gab keine
sehr interessanten Geschäfte -,
dass jemandem der Korpusdeckel
runtergefallen sei.
Ich war leicht irritiert,
weil das ab und zu vorkam.
Aber dann gab es immer
dieses spitzbübische Lachen.
Und das fehlte.
Dann fiel der Pultdeckel
noch einmal runter ...
* Knall *
... und wieder reagierte niemand.
- Da ist doch etwas.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich verstand anfangs gar nicht,
um was es ging.
Ich hörte einfach diese ... Töne.
Es waren Töne,
die ich gar nicht einordnen konnte.
Ich sass gerade wieder,
als irgendjemand schrie:
"Sofort alle auf den Boden!"
* Bedrohliche Musik *
* Knall *
(Theiler) Dann kam jemand
hochgerannt und sagte,
wir müssten uns verstecken.
- Da schiesst einer!
Was?
* Schuss *
Scheisse!
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Der Tisch!
* Schuss *
Ich dachte dann sofort
an den 11. September in New York.
Ich meine, wir sind
eine internationale Stadt,
ein internationaler Kanton.
Irgendjemand verübt da ein Attentat
auf den Kantonsrat.
Ich ging in die Staatskanzlei und
sagte, man müsse die Polizei rufen.
Und es knallte immer noch.
Und ...
... ich kriegte eine riesige Angst.
* Schüsse *
Ich ging in den Keller runter.
Aber ich fand,
ich dürfe kein Feigling sein.
Es knallte immer noch.
Ich ging dann sofort hinauf.
Und ...
Das Schlimmste
war dann Monika Hutter.
Sie lag dort vor der Tür.
* Traurige Musik *
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Ich liege
mit vielen Leuten auf dem Boden.
Wir liegen übereinander.
Meine Kollegin, die unter mir lag,
sagte, wir würden alle sterben.
"Manuela, wir sterben alle."
Sie könne nicht mehr atmen.
Weil ich
direkt unter einem Fenster lag ...
... stand ich auf
und öffnete das Fenster.
Dabei schaute ich zum ersten Mal
in den Raum rein.
Ich sah einerseits ... äh ...
... dass überall Stühle lagen,
alles war umgestossen.
Meine Kolleginnen und Kollegen
lagen auf dem Boden.
Ich schaute auf einen Mann,
der ein paar wenige Meter
von mir entfernt stand -
in der Nähe der Eingangstür.
Auf seiner Weste stand "Polizei".
Seine Verkleidung als Polizist ...
Die hatte er nicht gemacht,
um die Leute zu verarschen.
Man sah auf den zweiten Blick,
dass es kein Polizist war.
Achtung! Das ist ein Polizeieinsatz!
(Josef Lang)
Das war ein Rollenspiel.
D.h., er hat ...
... die Rolle dessen gespielt,
der Ordnung macht,
der die Mafia -
wir alle waren für ihn die Mafia -
ausradiert.
Er hatte genug Munition dabei,
um uns alle umzubringen.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
So nahm dieses Attentat
dann seinen Lauf.
Ich war unter dem Tisch.
Ich dachte,
dass ich so ein wenig geschützt sei,
dass er mich nicht direkt sieht.
Trotzdem
schoss er immer in die Reihe rein.
Mein ...
... Nachbar links wurde
von einem Schuss am Hals getroffen.
Er fiel dann tot um.
Er war vor mir.
* Traurige Musik *
Ich möchte das mal ansehen.
Das ist krass.
Wir machten mit der Schule
eine Herbstwanderung.
Ich wollte eigentlich
mit in den Kantonsrat.
Aber mein Papi meinte,
es passe nicht,
weil sie Abstimmungen hätten.
Ich könne ein andermal mit.
Wir fuhren mit dem Schiff
über den Zugersee nach Hause.
Er sagte, wir könnten Daddy winken.
Papi hatte immer diese Schuhe an.
Die waren bequem.
- Mhm.
Kari war ein liebenswerter,
fröhlicher Mensch.
Er hatte viel Freude
an seinen Kindern.
Er unternahm viel mit ihnen.
Wir konnten viele Dinge
gemeinsam machen.
Und ja ...
Es war einfach ... ja ... schön.
Er war viel für uns da,
obwohl er
noch viele andere Sachen machte.
Für Kinder ist es am schönsten,
wenn du das Gefühl hast,
er habe nur Zeit für dich.
Man musste nicht zweimal fragen,
ob er spielt.
Ich kann mich nicht mehr wirklich
an ihn erinnern.
Aber wenn ich Fotos anschaue ...
... sieht er einfach
immer glücklich aus.
Mhm.
Bei mir auch:
Ich war gerade zwei Jahre alt.
Ich habe eigentlich
gar keine Erinnerung an ihn -
daran, wie er war.
Ich zählte jeden einzelnen Schuss.
Ich war im Militär.
Ich wusste,
dass das Magazin leer sein musste
und dachte, dann sei fertig.
Dann wechselte er das Magazin.
Das war der Moment,
in dem ich merkte,
dass das ernst ist,
dass das gefährlich ist.
Mir gingen dort
wahnsinnige Sachen durch den Kopf.
Einerseits dachte ich,
wenn er schon neu lädt,
wäre das die Gelegenheit,
ihn anzugreifen.
Ich traute mich aber nicht.
Also legte ich mich
zurück auf den Boden ...
... zu meinen Kolleginnen
und wartete,
bis er in meiner Nähe war.
Er stieg auch auf die Tische rauf
und schoss direkt auf uns runter.
Daher ...
Für mich war eigentlich klar,
dass ich sterben werde.
* Schüsse *
Ich wusste nicht, ob ich im Saal
bin, in der Kantonsratssitzung.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
es sei ein Traum,
ich würde schlafen und etwas träumen
und wenn ich erwache,
sei der Traum vorbei.
Aber leider war es etwas anderes.
Es gab einen Moment,
in dem ich spürte,
dass ein Schuss
durch meine Haare ging.
Da wusste ich, dass ich
den Kopf zurücknehmen musste.
Der einzige Moment, in dem ich
stark an den Tod dachte ...
... war, als ich überlegte:
"Ich will nicht so jung sterben
wie meine Mutter."
Sie starb mit 41.
Als ich unter dem Tisch lag ...
... wollte ich mich schützen.
Ich stellte dann
meinen Aktenkoffer hinter mich,
weil ich dachte,
dann würde er mich nicht sehen.
In dem Moment stand er wohl so,
dass er sah, wie ich mich bewegte.
Darum hat er darauf geschossen.
Dann erwischte es mich an der Hand.
Polizei! Motor ausmachen!
- Hände auf das Lenkrad!
Gut. Gleiche Höhe.
Hände aufs Lenkrad!
Es war ein normaler Arbeitstag -
bis zu dem Zeitpunkt,
als mich der Kommandant
der Kantonspolizei anrief.
Ich hatte das Gefühl,
es sei eine Übung.
Es hing eine Übung in der Luft.
Ich dachte, dass die Übung zu
dem Zeitpunkt etwas unglücklich sei.
Aber ich merkte schnell -
aufgrund seines Tonfalls -,
dass es keine Übung ist.
Ich hatte dort ein Büro
bei der Stadtpolizei,
also am Kolinplatz.
Somit war ich sehr nahe
am Regierungsgebäude.
Ich rüstete mich dann minimal aus
und rannte
über den Landsgemeindeplatz runter.
Weiter.- Hände aufs Lenkrad!
Hände aufs Lenkrad!
Rausholen. Ruhig.
Plötzlich klingelte mein Telefon -
das Interventionstelefon.
"Schiesserei im Regierungsgebäude.
Das kann doch nicht sein."
Morgen haben wir die Vereidigung.
Schlechter Moment für eine Übung.
Was?
Okay, ich verstehe. Wir kommen.
Abbruch!
Ihr könnt verfügen. Guido, Einsatz.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
* Polizeisirene *
Viel mehr eingefahren
als die Schüsse ...
... sind mir seine Schreie.
Diese hasserfüllte Stimme.
Ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern,
jemals eine Stimme gehört zu haben,
die so hasserfüllt war.
Auch später, im Schlaf,
verfolgten mich nicht die Schüsse,
sondern seine Stimme.
Ich hoffte einfach,
dass er mich nicht trifft.
Darum kroch ich auch unter das Pult
und versuchte, mich
hinter dem Koffer zu verstecken.
Weil ich ... ja ...
... nicht bereit war, zu sterben.
* Schüsse und Schreie *
Ich hatte
erst ein paar Wochen vorher
meinen jetzigen Mann kennengelernt.
Ich fand, dass es schade sei,
dass wir
genau in dieser Verliebtheitsphase
schon wieder Abschied voneinander
nehmen müssen.
Dann schoss er weiter.
Dann wusste ich,
dass das Magazin wieder leer war.
Dann hörte ich Schritte.
Das waren seine.
Und dann gab es einen Knall.
* Knall *
Mein erster Gedanke war:
eine Handgranate.
Der zweite: keine Handgranate.
Weil ich wusste,
dass ich nicht mehr leben würde.
Am Schluss hörte ich ...
... wie das Sturmgewehr
auf den Boden fällt.
Und dann einen Pistolenschuss.
Dann war mir klar, dass er
sich selber umgebracht hatte.
Es war mir klar, dass er auf uns
mit dem Sturmgewehr schiesst,
mit der Waffe des Soldaten.
Sich selber erschiesst er
mit der Waffe des Offiziers,
mit der Waffe der Ehre.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Vorbei.
* Düstere Musik *
Dann kam ich in den Saal rein
und das war so schlimm.
Die Schreie und ...
... der Geschmack von Blut
und von dieser Bombe,
die er ja noch platzen lassen liess,
fuhr einem so in die Nase.
Das ging einfach
durch Mark und Bein.
Wenn ich daran denke,
rieche ich den Geruch.
Das war schlimm.
Auf dem Weg nach oben,
also schon im Treppenhaus,
sah es natürlich schlimm aus.
Und im Saal drin noch schlimmer.
Es brannte noch auf den Pulten.
Es hatte Rauch.
Es war einfach ein totales Chaos.
Es ging eigentlich darum:
"Wo ist der mögliche Täter?"
"Ist er weg? Ist er noch hier?
Schiesst er vielleicht plötzlich?"
Die Interventionseinheit Luchs
brauchte ich,
weil wir die Lage
zuerst in den Griff kriegen mussten
und nicht uns selbst und Dritte
wieder gefährden wollten.
* Polizeisirene *
(Hodel) Wir fuhren so schnell
es ging Richtung Regierungsgebäude -
bis zur Treppe.
Unmittelbar vor der Treppe,
bevor man reingeht,
hatte ich das erste Mal Kontakt
mit einem Vorgesetzten.
Eine der Schlüsselinformationen
für mich war:
"Achtung, der Täter
trägt eine Polizeiuniform."
Ich sagte ihm:
"Es hat viele Verletzte."
"Es hat Tote."
"Es ist völlig unübersichtlich."
Wir hatten noch nicht wirklich
Klarheit, ob es nur ein Täter war.
Jungs, bereit?
- Links bereit.
Rechts bereit.
- Rücken bereit.
Wir machten dann die Tür auf.
Ich ging ins Zentrum rein.
Wir sahen, dass rechts
noch die selbst gemachte Bombe war.
Die brannte immer noch.
Es rauchte immer noch.
Kontakt rechts.
Was wir zu diesem Zeitpunkt
noch nicht wussten:
Wir waren nicht die
ersten Polizisten, die drin waren.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Wenn mein Finger in der Situation
auf dem Abzug gewesen wäre,
wäre es möglich gewesen, dass ich
einen Kameraden erschossen hätte ...
... und damit
hätte weiterleben müssen.
Nach ein, zwei Sekunden
hatten wir ihn identifiziert.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Ich realisierte,
dass ich berichten musste.
Also, ja, ich musste damit ...
... auf den Sender.
Wir wussten ja nicht,
was weiter ist
und ob wir da je rauskommen würden.
Hey.
Was läuft im Kantonsratssaal?
* Telefon *
Hallo?
- Hier ist Lucia.
Wie geht's?
- Es ist etwas passiert.
Eine Schiesserei.
- Was? Stimmt das wirklich?
Ja. Können wir
eine Liveschaltung machen?
Bist du sicher? Live?
- Ja, los!
Nach diesem Pistolenschuss
habe ich einen Filmriss.
Als ich wieder zu mir kam, ohne
zu merken, dass ich zu mir kam ...
... äh ...
... lief ich durch den Gang,
durch meinen Gang.
Dann kam ich an jemanden ran.
Und ich sagte:
"Du, Rolf, es ist vorbei."
Er bewegte sich nicht.
Ich dachte, er sei bewusstlos.
Dann der Nächste.
Heinz Grüter.
"Heinz, du kannst aufstehen,
es ist vorbei."
Er bewegte sich auch nicht.
Ich dachte, er sei auch bewusstlos.
Dann ging ich aus dem Saal raus.
Ich wusste nicht ...
... dass hinter mir zwölf
bzw. mit dem Täter 13 Tote sind.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Der erste Anruf, den ich kriegte,
kam von Paul Hutter:
"Was ist mit meiner Frau?
Wo ist meine Frau?"
"Kannst du sie mir geben?"
Ich konnte Paul ja nicht sagen,
was wirklich ...
... passiert ist.
Ich sagte:
"Paul, ich kann es dir nicht sagen."
Und ja, da wusste man ja schon,
dass sie das erste Opfer war ...
... das er erwischt hatte. Leider.
Das sind schon Momente ...
... die einem heute noch nahegehen.
Unsere Reporterin Lucia Theiler
ist vor Ort.
Lucia, was ist passiert?
Kurz nach 10.30 Uhr
hörte ich den ersten Knall.
Ich dachte, das Haus falle zusammen.
Dann sah ich, wie die Leute
wegrannten und sich versteckten.
Ich bin hinter einem Tisch.
Die Polizei
gibt uns noch keine Entwarnung.
Die Polizei ist also vor Ort.
Hat man den Mann erwischt?
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen.
Ich sehe, wie die Polizeiautos
um das Haus fahren,
aber ob der Täter gefasst ist,
kann ich dir nicht sagen.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Kontakt links.
Eine Hand hatte er unter dem Körper.
Die zweite Hand
war wie zwischen den Beinen.
Dann hiess es plötzlich:
"Achtung, Handgranate."
Es hätte ja sein können.
Ich sah die Hände nicht.
Wenn ich die einfach nach vorne
ziehe und er hätte eine gehabt,
wäre es gefährlich gewesen.
"Ich, AHV-Nr. 590.44.321, erkläre:
Im Falle einer Verletzung
will ich keine medizinische Hilfe,
werde keine bezahlen
und habe keine Versicherung."
Wo bist du denn?
Und wo sind die anderen?
Bist du überhaupt in Sicherheit?
Jetzt ist gerade Regierungsrätin
Ruth Schwerzmann raufgekommen.
Sie kam ins Zimmer
und fragte nach ihren Leuten.
Offenbar geht die Suche los.
Die Suche nach diesem Mann?
Das ist ein riesiger Schock,
wenn es plötzlich knallt und raucht.
Die Leute rannten einfach weg.
Man weiss noch nicht, wohin.
Ich weiss, dass wir dringend
aus dem Zimmer mussten.
Ich war noch am Telefon und musste
dringend einen Schluss finden.
Es ist so, dass in dem Moment
ein Polizist heraufgekommen ist.
Er gibt vermutlich
Informationen dazu,
wie es weitergeht.
Ich melde mich in ein paar Minuten.
Lucia Theiler
aus dem Kantonsratssaal in Zug,
wo sich offenbar
ein Attentat ereignet hat.
Bleiben Sie dran, wir halten Sie
mit Informationen auf dem Laufenden!
Der Polizist
führte uns dann nach draussen.
Dann gingen wir die Treppe runter.
Dort war dann schon ...
Das Ausmass des Ganzen hat sich dort
ein bisschen abgezeichnet.
(Hodel) Es kam plötzlich
eine zweite Meldung rein:
"Achtung, ein zweiter Täter."
Nicht verstanden, wiederholen bitte!
"Achtung,
ein zweiter Täter auf dem Dach."
Verstanden. Zusammenkommen!
Wir haben vielleicht
noch einen zweiten Attentäter -
auf dem Dach.
Den holen wir uns, los!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Dann gingen wir in der schnellen
Verschiebung bis unters Dach.
Dort gab es noch
eine schmale Treppe.
Es war nicht möglich,
dass mehr als eine Person
direkt Waffenhoheit
auf dem Dach erstellen konnte.
Ihr zwei geht rauf,
wir sichern hier unten.
Bereit?
- (Alle) Check.
Go!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
Dann wollte ich meinen Koffer, also
meine Unterlagen zusammenräumen.
Und ich musste ...
... beide Hände brauchen.
Das ging aber nicht,
weil die Schmerzen in der Hand
so stark wurden und es blutete.
Also liess ich es liegen
und ging dann raus.
Das war wirklich
ein trauriger Anblick.
Dann kam eine Frau
und gab mir ein weisses Tüchlein.
* Dramatische Musik *
(Hodel) Es war übrigens
kein zweiter Täter,
sondern eine Person,
die bis aufs Dach geklettert war.
Von dem Zeitpunkt an ...
... war das Regierungsgebäude
im Polizeijargon sauber.
Alles gut, Sie sind in Sicherheit.
- Danke.
Jungs, wir bringen ihn runter.
Es kamen Kollegen auf mich zu,
die sagten, dass da
ein schwer verletzter Kollege sitze,
und fragten, ob ich helfen könne.
Ich habe dann ...
... schnell gesehen, dass er
ein zerschossenes Gesicht hatte.
Er war schwer verletzt.
Und ich sagte ...
... wir sollten ihn auf einen Stuhl
setzen und mit dem Stuhl ...
... zum Feuerwehrauto gehen.
- Als ich die Treppe runterging ...
... sass ein Mann auf einem Stuhl.
Und über seinem Gesicht,
über seinem Kopf ...
... war ein Tuch.
Und meine Fraktionskollegin
Manuela Weichelt ...
... stand neben ihm.
Das schien logisch.
Ich wusste, dass sie eine
Krankenschwesterausbildung hatte.
Trotz seiner schweren Verletzungen
war er voll ansprechbar.
Ich konnte ihm die Hand geben
und sagen,
wo wir gerade durchfuhren ...
... und dass wir bald
beim Kantonsspital seien.
Wir kamen an und die Chefärzte
standen schon
vor dem Notfall bereit.
Der Stuhl war immer dabei.
Wir trugen ihn mit dem Stuhl raus.
Ich weiss noch, dass ich sagte:
"Ihr dürft nicht erschrecken.
Ich nehme das Tuch weg."
Die Gesichter dieser Chefärzte
sehe ich heute noch.
Sie waren schwer ...
Sie erschraken wahnsinnig.
Ich sagte ihnen dann,
dass wir noch keine
medizinische Unterstützung hatten
und fragte, ob ich Morphium,
Spritzen und Nadeln mitnehmen könne.
Das brachten sie mir dann
und gaben mir einen Arzt mit.
Es ging dann schnell, bis
medizinische Unterstützung da war.
* Sirenen *
Ich machte dann
noch mal Liveschaltungen,
erinnere mich aber daran,
dass ich diese
als viel anspruchsvoller wahrnahm,
als die von drinnen,
weil ich das Ausmass erahnt hatte
und weil ich auch realisiert hatte,
dass ich ...
... berichten
und nicht beschönigen wollte.
Zugleich wollte ich aber auch ...
... respektvoll gegenüber möglichen
Opfern und deren Angehörigen sein.
Zudem gab es schon Gerüchte
von Namen und Tätern usw.
Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir uns
in der Redaktion einig waren,
dass wir weder Gerüchte ansprechen
noch Namen erwähnen.
Elmar Herger, was können Sie
zur Zahl der Opfer sagen?
Es ist die Rede von 14 Toten,
darunter Regierungsräte.
Können Sie das bestätigen?
Die Polizei hat bestätigt,
dass es sich um 14 Opfer handelt.
Noch ist unklar,
ob Regierungsräte darunter sind.
Es schwirren viele Gerüchte herum.
Die Zuger Regierungsrätin Monika
Hutter soll unter den Toten sein.
Ich weiss es nicht. Die Polizei
gibt derzeit nichts bekannt.
Vor einer Stunde gab die Zuger
Polizei an einer Medienkonferenz
erste Informationen bekannt.
Hat die Polizei schon Indizien
über die Täterschaft?
Man geht von einem Einzeltäter aus.
Es handelt sich offenbar
um einen Schweizer ...
* Melancholische Musik *
* Sie schluchzt. *
* Sanfte Pop-Ballade *
(Radio) Das Thema des Tages: die
Bluttat im Zuger Kantonsparlament.
Der Amokläufer war mit einem
Sturmgewehr der Schweizer Armee
und einer Pistole bewaffnet.
Der Mann habe offensichtlich
aus Rache und Wut gehandelt.
Ein Zusammenhang mit den Terror-
anschlägen in den USA bestehe nicht,
erklärten die Zuger Behörden.
Möglicher Auslöser für die
Wahnsinnstat könnte der Umstand sein,
dass das Zuger Obergericht diese
Woche Beschwerden abgewiesen hat.
Der Täter
warf mit diesen Beschwerden
mehreren bekannten Zuger Amtsträgern
Missbräuche ihrer Stellung vor.
Die traurige Bilanz:
14 Mitglieder von Regierung
und Parlament werden getötet,
andere verletzt,
einige von ihnen schwer.
Es gab nicht  e i n  Opfer.
Er ging blindlings rein
und knallte drauflos.
Er suchte nicht einen Mann
oder eine Frau,
er wollte einfach ein Drama ...
... bewirken.
Die erste Salve
ging direkt bei mir durch.
Zwei hinter mir sind tot,
und ein Kantonsrat,
der vor mir sass, ist auch tot.
Mich streifte es nur.
Sie sehen hier,
dass der Schuss hier reinging.
Es scheint Schrot gewesen zu sein.
Das ist hier umhergewirbelt.
Der Arzt konnte mir
fünf kleine Schrotkörner entfernen.
Es ist unvorstellbar.
Ich weiss nicht,
warum ich noch lebe.
Es tut mir leid für alle,
die sterben mussten.
Ich war an diesem Morgen
an der Regionaldekanenkonferenz.
Plötzlich kam die Meldung,
in Zug sei etwas passiert.
Dann sagte der Generalvikar:
"Alfredo, ich glaube,
du solltest nach Hause gehen."
Dann packte ich sofort
meine Sachen zusammen ...
... und fuhr nach Zug.
Mit etwas Herzklopfen,
muss man sagen.
Dann ging ich in die ...
... Stadt -
ins Gebäude der Kantonalbank.
Dort lief alles zusammen.
Es war wirklich
ein riesiges Durcheinander.
Nachdem das ganze Regierungsgebäude
eigentlich sicher war,
ging es sehr schnell darum,
wer verletzt und v.a., wer tot ist.
Die Angehörigen
hatten natürlich das Bedürfnis,
möglichst schnell zu wissen,
ob ihr Vater, ihre Mutter,
ihr Bruder usw. unter den Toten ist.
Es war ein enormer Druck.
Die Familien machten sich
logischerweise sofort Sorgen.
Das konnten wir dann halbwegs
über eine Hotline auffangen.
Ich bastelte an dem Morgen noch.
Dadurch hatte ich
kein Radio bei mir.
Kein Telefon, nichts.
Dann kochte ich das Mittagessen.
Dann kam der Anruf.
Eben:
Im Kantonsrat sei geschossen worden.
Ruth, meine Schwägerin,
war vor Ort und rief dann an,
dass ich hingehen solle.
Gibt es auch eine Anlaufstelle
für Angehörige?
Ja, das Gebäude
der Zuger Kantonalbank,
das neben dem Regierungsgebäude
steht,
wurde nach dem Vorfall
sofort geschlossen.
Dort wurde die Einsatzzentrale
eingerichtet.
Dorthin können sich
auch Angehörige wenden,
die hier vor Ort erscheinen
und nach ihren Angehörigen fragen.
Sie werden dann
in das Gebäude geleitet
und werden dort
auch psychologisch betreut.
Mein Auftrag lautete dann ...
Es hiess, dass die Angehörigen
informiert worden seien.
Im zweiten Stock der Kantonalbank
gebe es einen grossen Raum,
in dem sich alle treffen,
ich solle mich darum kümmern.
Dann ging ich dort hinauf.
Und langsam, langsam ...
... trafen dann
erschütterte Menschen ein.
Alle warteten und warteten.
Dann sah man
wieder Leute vom Kantonsrat,
die rumliefen.
Irgendwie dachte man immer:
"Was ist los?"
"Sagt mir doch endlich,
was los ist!"
"Wieso seid ihr hier
und Kari nicht?"
Ja.
Im Nebenzimmer war ...
... die Polizei mit ein paar Leuten.
Ich ging ein paarmal zu ihnen rein
und sagte:
"Leute,
ich muss denen etwas sagen können."
Man wählte dann einen
sehr pragmatischen Weg und hat ...
... Leute beauftragt,
die alle kennen.
Jemand davon
war der damalige Landschreiber.
Und ich war einer.
Wir waren vom Vorgehen her
ziemlich hemdsärmelig.
Wir gingen mit einem normalen
Schreibblock zurück in den Saal.
Dann gingen wir von einer
getöteten Person zur nächsten.
Er sagte dann den Namen und Vornamen
und ich sagte, woher die Person kam
und was ihr Beruf war.
So versuchte man,
das zusammenzustellen.
Dann riefen sie uns
in ein Zimmer ...
... und übermittelten
die traurige Nachricht,
ja, dass Kari gestorben war und ...
... nicht überlebt hatte.
Beim heutigen Amokanschlag
auf das Regierungsgebäude
sind Herr Peter Bossard,
Regierungsrat ...
... Herr Jean-Paul Flachsmann,
Regierungsrat,
und Frau Regierungsrätin
Monika Hutter zu Tode gekommen.
Auf der Seite des Parlamentes
beklagen wir den Tod
des Kantonsratspräsidenten
Herbert Arnet ...
... des Kantonsrates
Döbeli, Martin ...
... Gretener, Karl ...
... Grüter, Heinz ...
... Häusler, Konrad ...
... Heimgartner, Dorly ...
... Iten, Erich ...
... Nussbaumer, Kurt ...
... Nussbaumer, Rolf ...
... Langenegger, Käthi ...
... und Wismer, Willi.
Sie schrien zum Teil los.
Sie schrien einfach alles raus.
Äh ...
Sie ...
... verstummten. Sie rannten ...
... in ihrer Verzweiflung ...
... nach Hause oder schauten,
was sie machen konnten.
Dann war die Sache vorbei.
So furchtbar schnell wie es kam,
war es vorbei.
Ich nehme die Gelegenheit war,
allen Angehörigen ...
... das tief empfundene Beileid ...
... der Restregierung auszusprechen.
Ja ...
Dann ...
... ging ich wieder nach Hause.
Ich weiss nicht.
Ich fühlte einfach gar nichts mehr.
Ich war total am Boden.
Ich fuhr zurück und ...
... und dann ging ich hinauf und ...
... habe ihnen
die traurige Nachricht ...
... überbracht.
Ich sagte, dass Papi
nicht mehr nach Hause komme.
Ich konnte es gar nicht fassen
oder realisieren ...
... was genau passiert ist.
Du verstehst es als Kind halt nicht.
* Traurige Musik *
Ich teile
diesen unvorstellbaren Schock ...
... mit den Betroffenen ...
... mit den Angehörigen ...
... mit dem ganzen Kanton Zug.
(TV) Der Verkehr um das Regierungs-
gebäude hier in Zug rollt wieder,
aber was man natürlich macht, ist,
Ermittlungen zu führen.
Das sieht man hinter mir.
Dort, wo Licht brennt,
ist die Untersuchungsbehörde
bei der Spurensicherung.
Man ermittelt im Haus,
aber auch im Umfeld des Täters.
Es ist ein schrecklicher Tag
und ich kann sagen,
es ist eine nationale Tragödie,
die sich hier abgespielt hat.
Ich habe jemanden bei mir,
der das Drama überlebt hat.
Es ist Rupy Enzler.
Er ist Journalist.
Er ist Nachrichtenchef
der Zuger Presse.
Rupy Enzler, was hat Ihnen heute
nach 10.30 Uhr das Leben gerettet?
Mich hat gerettet,
dass ich nach den Schüssen
und der Stimme,
die "In Deckung!" rief ...
... intuitiv auf den Boden sank,
den Tisch umwarf
und die Tischplatte als Schutzschild
für mich und meine Kollegin nutzte.
Hallo.
Lucia! Gott sei Dank!
Ist bei dir alles gut?
- Mhm.
Wenn wir etwas für dich tun können,
sag es bitte.
... zwischen fünf und acht Minuten -
nicht mal.
Man musste einfach warten ...
- Ich habe Hunger.
Ich habe noch nichts gegessen.
- Okay.
Ich hole etwas zu essen.
Wollt ihr auch etwas?
- (Alle) Gerne, ja.
Es ging los mit Schreien
von Verletzten,
von Leuten,
die am Sterben waren ...
Setz dich hin!
Willst du erzählen?
(TV) In der Nähe des Parlaments-
gebäudes fand die Polizei ein Auto,
das offenbar
dem Amokschützen gehörte.
Darin habe es weitere Waffen gehabt.
Bezüglich des Tatmotivs fanden wir
am Tatort eine Art Bekennerbrief.
Er ist mit "Tag des Zornes
für die Zuger Mafia" betitelt.
Er schreibt darin,
dass der Tag des Zornes für
die Zuger Mafia stattgefunden habe.
Er sagt, die Zuger Justiz habe viele
Verfahren verschleppt und verdeckt.
Er bezichtigt verschiedene Chauffeure
der Zugerland Verkehrsbetriebe
des Alkoholkonsums.
Er hat entsprechende Klagen
deponiert.
Er ist überall abgeblitzt
und das war wohl der Grund,
warum er diese Amoktat beging.
(Sacchi) Ich telefonierte dann
mit dem Pfarrer von St. Michael.
Wir machten ab,
dass die Kirche am Abend offen ist.
Es kam dann auch bald im Radio,
dass man sich treffen könne.
Dann war die Kirche St. Oswald
natürlich bumsvoll.
Man traf sich dann dort
und machte ...
... ganz schlichte Gebete.
Dann gingen die Leute ...
... auf den Landsgemeindeplatz.
* Düstere Musik *
Hoi zusammen.
- Hoi.
Ich war im Einsatz
und gebe meine Dienstwaffe ab.
Hier ist meine.
Wir haben keinen Schuss abgegeben.
- Ah ja?
Gehen wir noch etwas trinken?
Lieber ein andermal.
Macht es gut!
- Merci.
Plötzlich hiess es von jemandem -
und zwar jemandem,
der im Kantonsratssaal drin war -,
dass die Polizei
den Täter erschossen habe.
Da ich ja das Zentrum hatte
und im Zentrum reingegangen war,
kam das im Prinzip auf mich zurück.
Kommandant Urs Hürlimann
kam dann runter und fragte:
"Hodel, wo sind die Waffen?"
Und ich sagte: "Urs, es ist gut."
"Wir haben die Waffen dem kriminal-
technischen Dienst abgegeben."
Er war sichtlich erleichtert,
dass wir es tatsächlich so gemacht
hatten, wie das trainiert wird.
Es zeigte sich einmal mehr:
"Trainiere, wie du kämpfst."
Wir hatten
keine einzige Schussabgabe.
Aber wenn es so gewesen wäre,
muss ich sagen,
dass das im Rahmen der Gesetzgebung
verhältnismässig gewesen wäre.
Eine klassische Gefahrenabwehr.
Ich muss auch sagen,
dass es für mich persönlich,
wenn ich in so einer Situation
angegriffen worden wäre ...
... auch ein Mittel gewesen wäre.
Darum hatten wir
die professionelle Truppe dabei
und weitere Kräfte hinzugezogen,
damit wir dort taktisch richtig ...
... und v.a. verhältnismässig
und rechtlich korrekt handelten.
Guten Morgen.
Ich möchte endlich wissen, wie es
mit meiner Entschädigung aussieht.
Das habe ich Ihnen
schon x-mal erklärt.
Mir sind die Hände gebunden.
Wieso denn?
Das Gesetz setzt Entschädigungen
für Zwangsenteignungen fest.
Sie nehmen uns noch das letzte Hemd.
Da müssen Sie sich nicht wundern,
wenn jemand ausrastet.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Wie der Typ in Zug halt.
Im Kantonsrat?
- Genau den meine ich.
* Bedrohliche Musik *
Auf Wiederhören!
Scheisskerl!
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Hodel) Links.
Sauber.
Rechts.
Links.
Sauber.
Die Wohnung ist sauber.
Die Kripo kann reinkommen.
Gut gemacht, Jungs.
Sichert die Wohnung draussen.
Danke, Jungs.
- Hallo zusammen.- Hoi.
Oh, schau mal!
Leck mich am Arsch!
"Ich hatte keine Mitwisser
und habe ganz alleine gehandelt."
Er hat an alles gedacht.
Der war ja verdammt gut vorbereitet.
(Halter) Man konnte ihn
schnell identifizieren.
Er war ja bekannt.
Dann hatte man schnell
einen Hinweis,
in welche Richtung es gehen könnte.
Heute würde man das
"Wutbürger" nennen.
Schau,
was ich im Kasten gefunden habe.
Ah.
- Und bei dir?
In den letzten Tagen hat er sich
v.a. mit Waffen, Amokläufen
und Bestattungsunternehmen
beschäftigt und ...
... Pornos geschaut.
- Also alles normal.
Der Brief ist für seine Mutter.
Das Testament
schrieb er schon im August.
* Handy *
Ja?
Wo?
Okay, wir sind in 20 Minuten dort.
Ich muss wieder los mit den Jungs.
- Schon wieder?
Die Welt dreht durch.
Tschüss.
- Viel Glück.
Hatten wir den
eigentlich auf dem Schirm?
Ein alter Bekannter - leider.
Mit 13
war er das erste Mal auf dem Posten,
weil er mit einem Luftgewehr
herumschoss.
Ab dann
war er regelmässig Gast bei uns.
Er hat schon immer rumgeballert?
- Mhm.
So ein kleiner, krimineller Psycho.
Verstösse gegen das Waffengesetz,
Drohungen gegen Leute ...
Vor Kurzem bedrohte er
einen Buschauffeur in einer Beiz.
Darum entwickelte sich
dieser juristische Kleinkrieg?
Jahrelang?
- Mhm.
Alle dachten, er sei ein Spinner.
Harmlos.
So kann man sich täuschen.
Genau das kackt mich an
an unserem Beruf.- Was?
Dass man so Idioten
nicht rausziehen kann.
Ich fühlte nie Wut
gegen den Attentäter.
Ich war eigentlich glücklich ...
... dass ich wusste, dass sich der
Attentäter selbst umgebracht hatte.
Ich bin überzeugt davon,
dass wir ihn noch mal sehen würden,
wenn er sich nicht umgebracht hätte.
(TV) Für die Zuger Justiz ist
der Täter kein unbeschriebenes Blatt:
Er wurde 1970 bereits durch
das Strafgericht in Zug verurteilt -
wegen diversen Vermögensdelikten ...
... Unzucht mit Kindern, öffent-
lichen, unzüchtigen Handlungen,
Urkundenfälschung
und Strassenverkehrsdelikten.
Er wurde damals zu 18 Monaten
Freiheitsentzug verurteilt,
aber stattdessen in eine Arbeits-
erziehungsanstalt eingewiesen.
Unsere Mami
hat das wirklich super gemacht.
Sie klebte in allen Zeitungen
und überall die Seiten zusammen,
sodass wir nie sahen,
wie er ausgesehen hat.
Ich bin auch froh,
dass wir das nie gesehen haben.
Ich frage mich eher, warum ...
Ja, also ...
Warum geht man so weit?
Die Frage nach dem Warum.
Warum hat es meinen Papi getroffen?
Eher das Warum und nicht, dass das
dieser bestimmte Mensch war.
* Spannungsgeladene Musik *
(Hodler) Polizei! Hände hoch!
Langsam abstellen!
Ich will die Hände sehen.
Hände hoch! Langsam
drei, vier Schritte nach vorne.
Stehen bleiben!
Langsam auf die Knie runter.
Langsam hinlegen.
Hände raus! Handflächen nach oben.
Beine überkreuzen.
Was ist denn los?
Ich habe gar nichts gemacht.
Bleiben Sie ganz ruhig.
Wurden Sie von Zug geschickt?
Das erfahren Sie alles
auf dem Posten.
Andere Hand auf den Rücken.
Können Sie atmen?
- Ja.
Aufstehen. Auf das Bein.
(Halter) Es gab natürlich Leute,
die mit dem Regierungs- oder
Verwaltungsteil im Clinch waren
und sich dann meldeten
oder Mails schrieben:
"Bravo, das soll auch bei uns
nur weitergehen."
Es gab auch wieder Drohungen.
Da mussten wir einfach reagieren.
Ich habe ja gar nichts gemacht.
- Bleiben Sie ganz ruhig.
Wurden Sie von Zug geschickt?
- Sie erfahren alles auf dem Posten.
Ja, wir haben ihn.
- Wer ist am Telefon?
Bleiben Sie ruhig.
- Wir bringen ihn.
Ich habe nichts gemacht.
Es gibt
eine einzige politische Frage ...
... die durch das Attentat
gestellt wurde -
abgesehen von Sicherheitsmassnahmen.
Das ist eine Waffengesetzgebung,
die einfach ...
... fahrlässig
und verantwortungslos war.
Vorderschaftrepetierflinte.
Vornehmer Begriff
für eine Pump-action.
Registriernummer W648107M.
- Moment, nicht so schnell!
W-6-4-8-1-0-7-M.
Hast du es?
- Yes.
Die hat er privat erworben -
neun Tage vor der Tat.
Im Kanton Bern. Ohne Waffenschein.
Dann haben wir SIG PE90.
Das neue Sturmgewehr.
- Mhm.
A214-0-0-3-2.
Privat erworben im Kanton Zürich.
1996/97.
Auch kein Waffenschein notwendig.
Die Pump-action z.B.,
die hatte er privat gekauft
und brauchte
keinen Waffenerwerbsschein dafür.
Sie stand in keinem Register.
Also, in keinem Register des Kantons
Bern, wo er die Waffe kaufte,
in keinem Register des Kantons
Zürich, wo er damals wohnte.
Der Kanton Zug konnte
also auch nicht davon erfahren.
Wenn der Kanton Zug erfahren hätte,
dass er ...
... so eine Waffe kauft,
hätten bei jedem Polizisten,
der in den Fall involviert war,
die Alarmglocken geläutet.
Wenn wir heute
so eine Situation haben und wissen,
dass von einer Person
eine Drohung ausgeht,
checkt man natürlich die Register.
Aber in diesem Fall
wussten wir nichts.
So ...
SIG Sauer, 232er.
Damit hat er sich selber erschossen,
oder?
Korrekt.
B-9-2 ...
... 1-4-4-2.
Legal erworben, 1996.
Im Waffenfachhandel in Zug.
Manchmal frage ich mich, ob wir
das Paradies für Waffenfreaks sind.
Komm, nicht die Waffe tötet, sondern
der, der sie in der Hand hält.
Hör auf, echt jetzt!
Zahlreiche Vorstrafen
und trotzdem kannst du dich legal
bis an die Zähne bewaffnen.
Du musst nur
in einen anderen Kanton gehen.
Alles hat seine Ordnung.
Niemand sagt etwas.
Bis es knallt.
Das entscheiden andere.
Ich kann der zuständigen Behörde
und der zuständigen Polizei
keinen Vorwurf machen.
Ich wüsste nicht, was sie anders
hätten machen können -
aufgrund der damaligen Gesetzeslage
und der damaligen Situation.
Es wurde auch noch
eine andere Kritik geäussert:
Man habe ihn
zu wenig ernst genommen.
Da muss ich sagen: Das ist Humbug.
Ich meine, sogar ein Regierungsrat
hatte ihn empfangen.
In welchem Kanton ...
... erhält ein Querulant
eine Audienz beim Regierungsrat?
Das ist ... Und ...
Der Chef des öffentlichen Verkehrs,
des ZVB,
mit dem er ja den Konflikt hatte,
hat dreimal mit ihm gesprochen,
glaube ich.
Wenn ich mich an das erste Gespräch
zurückerinnere,
als ich versuchte, ihm darzulegen,
was die Untersuchungsresultate sind,
interessierte ihn das
eigentlich nicht.
Er meint, er habe recht damit,
was er mir geschrieben habe.
Alles andere interessiert ihn nicht.
Das ist einfach
komplett rechthaberisch.
Wenn ihm jemand nicht recht gibt,
ist das ein Feind.
Und dass ...
... er sich
in den letzten paar Wochen
aus einem Querulanten
in eine Bombe verwandelt ...
... konnte man nicht wissen.
* Handy *
Hallo?
Ja.
Das habe ich nicht gemerkt.
Das Portemonnaie auch? Mhm.
Ja ... äh ... Ich komme vorbei.
Aber nicht mehr heute.
Morgen, wenn das okay ist.
Ja.
Danke. Ihnen auch.
Merci.
Ist alles okay?
- Das war die Polizei.
Sie fanden meinen Mantel und mein
Portemonnaie im Kantonsratssaal.
Ich habe das gar nicht gemerkt.
- Hauptsache, es ist noch da.
Unser Chef
organisierte ein Debriefing.
Wir schauten einfach noch einmal
auf den Tag zurück.
Ich glaube, wir konnten
einfach nicht nach Hause gehen -
in dieser Aufgelöstheit
und mit den vielen Fragen.
Ich glaube, es ging etwas darum,
uns zu sammeln ...
... und ein bisschen runterzukommen,
sofern das überhaupt möglich war.
Wir haben uns auch ...
... gefragt,
ob wir das richtig gemacht hatten,
so zu berichten
und das so zu machen.
Es ist wichtig, dass wir noch
einen Moment zusammen sein können.
Vielleicht ist es zu früh
für eine Sendekritik.
Aber ich habe alles durchgehört,
was im Zusammenhang mit dem Attentat
über unseren Sender ging:
sachlich ...
... und korrekt.
Wir waren nahe dran ...
... und bewahrten trotzdem
den nötigen Abstand.
Gut gemacht. Alle.
V.a. Lucia.
Greift zu! Guten Appetit!
(Sacchi) Ich weiss noch genau,
dass wir in St. Michael standen.
Wir sprachen über den Gottesdienst
und was für Zeichen wir setzen.
Dann sagten wir:
"Gut, wir zünden für alle Toten ...
... eine Kerze an."
Das war unsere Ausgangslage.
Wir sprachen gar nicht von Opfern
und Täter,
sondern einfach von denen,
die gestorben waren.
Am Sonntagabend
vor dem 1. Oktober ...
... erhielt ich einen Anruf.
Jemand am Telefon sagte mir ...
... ob ich gehört habe,
dass die Geistlichkeit
die 15. Kerze anzünden wolle -
am Trauergottesdienst
in St. Michael.
Die Nacht schlief ich nicht viel.
Das beschäftigte mich so stark.
(Sacchi) Man stellt die Verstorbenen
unter das Licht Gottes.
Man übergibt die Verstorbenen
an Gott.
Gott vorzuschreiben,
wem er sein Licht,
seine Barmherzigkeit,
seine Vergebung schenkt,
ist nicht unsere Sache.
Wir glauben, dass Gott weiss,
was er jetzt ...
Also, wie er weitergeht.
Das wissen wir ja nicht.
Wir können das nicht wissen.
Wir sollen ja auch nicht urteilen.
Also ist das wirklich
das Licht Gottes, das allen gehört.
Robi Bisig und Ruth Schwerzmann
gingen in die Sakristei,
um mit der Geistlichkeit zu sprechen
und zu sagen,
dass sie die 15. Kerze
wirklich nicht anzünden sollen.
Sie kamen dann zurück
und haben beide geweint.
Sie hatten keine grosse Hoffnung.
Dann sagte ich zu Robi: "Komm, wir
gehen noch einmal in die Sakristei."
Wir gingen in die Sakristei
und ich sagte einfach:
"Bitte, bitte,
zündet diese Kerze nicht an!"
Ich konnte nachvollziehen,
dass das schwierig ist.
Von meinem Glauben her ...
... konnte ich das trotzdem
nicht ganz loslassen.
Gerade er
braucht ja das Licht Gottes.
Ein Täter braucht das besonders.
Und ihn da jetzt auszuschliessen,
habe ich ...
... persönlich
wie eine Verurteilung gesehen.
Das steht mir gegenüber
eines Verstorbenen einfach nicht zu.
Ich schrieb dazumal auch sofort:
"Bitte macht das nicht!
Das verletzt meine Gefühle
und wahrscheinlich
auch die Gefühle von anderen."
(Sacchi) Regierungsrat Bisig
kam noch mal in die Sakristei.
Er sagte,
er garantiere wirklich für nichts,
wenn wir die 15. Kerze anzünden.
Dann gingen wir raus und sind ...
... eingezogen, ohne zu wissen,
wie wir es machen werden.
Wir wussten nicht, was sie machen.
Wir hofften einfach nur.
Wir entzünden an der Osterkerze ...
... Kerzen zum Zeichen dafür,
dass unsere Verstorbenen
im Licht Gottes sind ...
... und auch in unseren Herzen.
Peter Bossard.
Karl Gretener.
Monika Hutter.
(Josef Lang) Ich spürte,
dass eine extreme Anspannung da war.
Ich hoffte schwer, dass
die 15. Kerze nicht angezündet wird,
obwohl ich den theologischen
Hintergedanken total verstand.
In dem Moment,
in dem ein Mensch tot ist,
gibt es nur noch einen Richter:
Das ist Gott.
* Dramatische Musik *
Dann flüsterte ich Kurt Koch -
ich sass neben ihm - zu:
"Gib mir die Kerze!"
* Dramatische Musik *
Wir müssen Abschied nehmen
von 14 Menschen ...
... die jäh aus ihrem Leben und
unserem Lebenskreis gerissen wurden.
Ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen:
Das hätte in der Kirche
einen Tumult gegeben, ganz sicher.
Das hätte niemand verstehen können.
Und ich nahm mir ...
... vor, wenn das passieren sollte,
ans Mikrofon zu gehen.
Das hätten wir
nicht tolerieren dürfen.
... diese grosse Sünde
zu vergeben ...
... und eine Kerze
auch dafür anzuzünden.
Ich spüre es: Es ist zu früh.
Aber ich übergebe eine Kerze
dem Regionaldekan.
Dir, lieber Alfredo.
Du wirst in deinem
pastoral-weisen Herzen spüren,
wann es möglich ist.
* Dramatische Musik *
Nein, ich fühlte mich
gar nicht erleichtert.
Ich hatte eine wahnsinnige Aufgabe.
Also ... ähm ...
Aber ...
Aufgaben muss man lösen.
Und ... ähm ...
Da hatte ich wirklich
auch Gottvertrauen,
dass das schon gut rauskommen wird.
(Langenegger) Danach erlebte ich
dennoch eine grosse Enttäuschung:
Beim Mittagessen, bei dem ich
die Plätze einweisen musste,
kam der Bischof dahergelaufen
und ich ging zu ihm hin und sagte:
"Herr Bischof,
vielen herzlichen Dank."
Als Antwort erhielt ich:
"Schon gut, aber normalerweise lässt
sich die Kirche nicht dreinreden."
Sie können sich vorstellen,
dass das ein Tiefschlag war.
Damit habe ich noch heute Mühe.
(Sacchi) Wir hatten das Gefühl,
dass wir mindestens ein Jahr
warten müssen.
Wir dachten aber, dass der Jahrestag
sicher nicht gehen würde.
Darum suchten wir dann
ein anderes Datum:
den Allerseelentag.
Da beten wir für alle Verstorbenen.
Die Kinder sind im Bett.
Geht das noch lange?
Geh du schon,
ich hinke etwas hinterher.
Es hat morgen
extrem viele Traktanden.
Morgen haben sie Sporttag.
- Mhm.
Soll ich den Tisch im Aklin
für Samstag reservieren?
Ja, mach doch.
Was ist das?
Eine Psychologin des Care Teams
hat angerufen.
Du hättest nie zurückgerufen.
Das habe ich vergessen.
- Vergessen?
Sag, frierst du nicht?
Sie wollte wissen, wie es dir geht.
- Super.
Wie soll es mir gehen?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Du sprichst ja auch mit mir
nicht darüber.
Bitte, nicht jetzt!
Ich vergleiche es mit einer Waage:
Wenn Sie auf der einen Seite
ein Kilo an Belastung haben ...
... dann ist das hier oben.
Wenn Sie aber hier
langsam etwas füllen
mit ein bisschen guten
und auch noch schönen Erinnerungen -
und die haben wir alle,
oder mit Menschen,
die wir lieb haben,
oder mit einem Hund,
einer Katze oder egal was -,
dann ...
Verstehen Sie?
Dann gleicht das ein bisschen aus.
Das bringt doch nichts!
Es sind alle tot.
Es geht mir nicht um die Toten.
Es geht mir um dich.
Reden hilft.
Stürzt ein Skispringer, muss er
sofort wieder auf die Schanze,
sonst springt er nie mehr.
- Ein blöder Vergleich!
Wieso?
Ich gehe an die Sitzung morgen.
- Schon gut.
Das bin ich meinen Kollegen
schuldig.
Es ist deine Entscheidung.
Ich bin hier.
Gute Nacht.
- Gute Nacht.
Ich komme gleich.
Ein Trauma verändert das Leben -
ob klein oder gross.
Es gibt Schädigungen und
Einschränkungen, die zurückbleiben.
Da kann man auf den Kopf stehen.
Ich stand danach
häufig am Morgen auf ...
... und versuchte,
das Frühstück zu machen.
Ich nahm Butter aus dem Kühlschrank
und schnitt eine Scheibe Brot ab,
wusste aber nicht mehr,
dass ich frühstücken wollte.
Ich hatte auch Schwierigkeiten,
Termine einzuhalten.
Ich hatte kein Zeitgefühl mehr.
Ich versuchte dann,
wieder zur Arbeit zu gehen.
Aber ich konnte keinen Satz
mehr fehlerfrei schreiben.
Es ging nicht mehr.
Ich konnte bis am Sonntag
nicht über den Fall sprechen.
Ich brachte es einfach nicht fertig.
Es war wie eine Blockade.
Ich wollte vielleicht
auch nicht reden,
aber ich konnte auch nicht reden.
Ich war einfach blockiert.
Es war so toll. Das müssen wir
unbedingt wieder mal machen.
Ja.
- (Junge) Auf jeden Fall.
(Junge) Nein!
- Boah, Volltreffer!
* Lachen *
Komm, wir schiessen auf ihn!
- Oh ja!
* Knall *
Wenn ich in einem Tram fuhr
und jemand so ein Kippfenster ...
... zuknallte,
weil ihm kalt war oder es zog ...
... erinnerte mich das
an einen Schuss.
Ich merkte dann aber schnell,
dass ich mich entspannen kann,
dass wir nicht
im Kantonsratssaal sind.
* Lachen *
Hey!
Alle auf die Knie!
(Leise) Du widerlicher Saukerl!
Runter habe ich gesagt!
Der Mensch ist eigentlich
von Geburt her darauf ausgelegt ...
... dass er sich sicher fühlt.
Daher hat er im besten Falle
auch ein Grundvertrauen.
Sobald das wegfällt,
durch was auch immer -
es kann etwas Kleines sein -,
verliert der Mensch
dieses Vertrauen,
das Vertrauen in das Leben
und möglicherweise das Vertrauen
in irgendeine Religion.
Er fühlt sich fortan unsicher.
Dann stolpert er unsicher
durch das Leben.
Hallo? Wir brauchen Hilfe.
Mein Mann
bedroht jemanden mit einer Waffe.
Er hat nichts getrunken.
Er war im Kantonsrat,
als das Attentat passierte.
Ganz, ganz wichtig finde ich ...
... dass man den Menschen ...
... in seiner Verletzung ...
... wahrnimmt.
In seiner medizinischen Verletzung,
in seiner Integrität
und in seiner seelischen Verletzung.
Entschuldigung für den Schneeball.
Können wir gehen?
Kommt, wir gehen.
Hey. Hey, hey, hey.
* Polizeisirene *
Es wird gut. Alles ist gut.
Es gibt nichts Demütigenderes,
aber wirklich nichts,
als einem Menschen,
der schwerst traumatisiert ist ...
... zu sagen:
"Du wirst wieder der, der du warst."
Es gibt kein anderes Leben.
Es gibt nur ein neues Leben.
Das alte ist vorbei.
Definitiv vorbei.
Ich konnte natürlich zwei Jahre
nicht arbeiten, weil ich ...
... nicht mehr
auf dem Beruf arbeiten konnte.
Es war einfach nicht mehr möglich.
Ich hatte keine Kraft
und kein Gefühl.
So musste ich mich dann einfach ...
... Arbeiten hingeben,
die ich nebenbei machte.
Ich machte mehr Büroarbeit
und mehr Administratives.
Aber ich habe teils
heute noch Schmerzen.
Ich muss teils heute noch, je nach
Wetterumschlag, Medikamente nehmen.
Aber ...
... die Schmerzen ertrage ich gut.
(Josef Lang)
Viele konnten sich nicht vorstellen,
den Saal zu besuchen.
Ich musste das sehen.
Das war Teil meiner Verarbeitung.
Als ich in den Saal kam,
sah man es sofort:
der Boden geschwärzt,
die Einschusslöcher usw. ...
Ich ging zuerst dorthin ...
... wo ich gelegen hatte.
Ich sah, dass meine Überlegung,
den Platz zu wechseln,
richtig war.
Diese Wände
waren völlig durchschossen.
Ich erschrak dann auch,
als ich sah, dass zwei Schüsse ...
... quer über mich und einer
längs über mich gegangen waren,
mich aber einfach nicht trafen.
Dann sprach ich auch mit ...
... Angehörigen.
Und etwas blieb mir.
Da musste ich weinen.
Der kleine Sohn eines Opfers
sagte mir:
"Schau, dieses Loch hier."
"Mit diesem Schuss
wurde mein Papi getötet."
Das gehört zu den ...
(Schluchzend)
Das war das Schlimmste.
Dieser kleine Junge.
Ich weiss,
dass ich mit jemandem sprach,
als wir uns das ansahen.
Aber ich weiss nicht, wer das war.
Ich war damals sehr interessiert,
aber jetzt
würde mich das nicht mehr ...
Heute würde ich das
nicht mehr sehen wollen.
Ich möchte auch nicht
in diesen Raum hinein.
(Annemarie) Es war noch schwierig,
den Schritt dort hinein zu machen.
Aber auf eine Art ...
Ja, man war dann mal drin
und man hat es gesehen.
Eine weitere Verarbeitung,
um das Ganze ...
... zu fassen und anzunehmen,
wie es ...
... war.
Das Pferd gab immer eine
gewisse Verbundenheit, denke ich.
Auch schon mit Kari.
Darum sagten wir,
dass das eine Zukunft ist,
mit der wir weiterarbeiten können.
Ja ...
Was wir in diesen 20 Jahren
erarbeitet haben ...
Wir konnten vieles ...
... weitermachen,
bei dem er auch noch mit dabei war.
Ich bin auch ein wenig stolz,
dass ich das so weiterführen konnte.
(Serena) Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass wir eigentlich ...
Alle Kinder
haben eine gute Ausbildung.
Wir konnten die Ziele,
die wir bis jetzt hatten,
ziemlich gut verfolgen.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl,
dass er uns hilft.
Eine Art Unterstützung, die er uns
von irgendwoher trotzdem gibt.
(Sacchi) Etwas,
das mich eigentlich immer bewegt:
Zu was für Untaten
wir Menschen fähig sind.
Das ist für mich
eigentlich unbegreiflich.
Aber ...
... es gehört irgendwie
zu unserer Welt.
Und darum ...
... beteten wir
nicht nur für den Attentäter
bzw. dachten an ihn,
sondern beteten für alle Menschen
und dachten an all diejenigen,
die sich nicht anders als mit Gewalt
zu helfen wissen.
(Weichelt-Picard) Ich musste
wenige Medikamente nehmen.
Ganz am Anfang etwas
für ein paar Nächte, um zu schlafen.
Ich musste auch nicht
zum Alkohol greifen.
Ich konnte mit meinen Freundinnen,
die mich stark gestützt haben,
mit meinem Partner
und der Zuger Bevölkerung,
die ich einfach phänomenal finde,
kommunizieren.
Ich dachte immer wieder,
dass es so viele Leute gibt,
die ein Trauma erlebten, die das
ganz alleine bewältigen müssen.
Wir hatten diesen riesigen Luxus,
dass wir die Zuger und
die Schweizer Bevölkerung hatten.
Ich fühlte mich extrem getragen.
* Glocke *
Ah.
Ja?
- Grüezi. Ich bin Lucia Theiler.
Ich möchte meine Sachen abholen.
- Frau Theiler, genau.
Moment!
Wie geht es Ihnen, Frau Theiler?
- Gut, danke.
Also, da haben wir ...
Da haben wir eine Tasche ...
... einen Mantel
und ein Portemonnaie.
Sehen Sie sich die Sachen
bitte genau an.
Es blieb in dem Chaos so viel liegen.
Gehört das Ihnen?
Ja. Ja, ja.
Ist das ...
5,6 mm Sturmgewehr 90.
Sie können von Glück sprechen,
dass Sie nicht beim Mantel waren.
Glück ...
Ja, Glück. Schicksal. Gottes Wille -
wie immer Sie es nennen wollen.
Sie leben.
Das ist doch die Hauptsache.
Einen schönen Tag.
- Das wünsche ich Ihnen auch.
* Melancholische Musik *
(Langenegger)
Ich habe mich manchmal gefragt,
wieso sich jemand
das Recht rausnehmen kann,
über Menschenleben zu urteilen.
Er erhält sicher irgendeine Strafe.
Es wäre nicht gut ...
... wenn der Herrgott
das einfach ungestraft ...
... stehen lassen würde.
Irgendwoher erhält er eine Strafe.
Man spürt natürlich in so
einer Situation besonders stark,
was eine Partnerschaft bedeutet.
In dem Moment
hätte ich nicht alleine sein wollen.
Anderthalb Jahre nach dem Attentat
haben wir dann geheiratet.
Und danach machten wir einen Anlass,
zu dem wir alle Überlebenden
einluden -
auch, um zu zeigen,
dass unsere Hochzeit
ein Akt der Verarbeitung war.
Und es kamen alle.
Es war natürlich
eine harte Geschichte.
Es machte einen etwas härter
für gewisse Sachen.
Es stumpfte einen gegen
gewisse Dinge vielleicht etwas ab,
teils wurde man
aber auch dünnhäutiger.
V.a. nachts finde ich es schlimm.
Und ganz vergessen wird man das nie.
* Melancholische Musik *
Was mich heute noch
sehr betroffen macht:
Es hatte so viele Leute
in diesem Saal,
die sich wirklich
für den Kanton engagiert haben,
für das Wohl der Leute.
Und die wurden jäh
aus ihrem Alltag gerissen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021